a lot of my artists pop art in pop
culture so the gummy bear was a piece
that I wanted to do what's commonly used
in some pop art is mug shot pieces I
have a sweet tooth and and gummy bears
came to mind I was like what if I just
supposed gummy bears against Department
of Corrections and kind of create this
contrast of essentially innocence lost
and for me it was kind of like wait what
did what did he do why how did that
happen I like people to attach their own
stories to it so whatever they can
relate to you know like implement their
message and create their story one small
step for man one big step for gummy
bears
[Music]
one of the promises I kind of made to
myself is if I'm gonna keep doing the
bear I have to keep evolving it so the
natural evolution in my mind was kind of
going from 2d to 3d tall myself had a
cast I just hit the ground running and I
did as much research as I could and I
just kept practicing and doing more and
more and more and more and more and
exploring the medium and really learn
now the definition of what it's like to
become a master like 10,000 hours and
how much work you have to put into
something because how I craft my pieces
now versus how I crafted them last year
versus how I crafted them the year
before that I thought I got two places
of perfection and they were better but
then I made those pieces better and then
those pieces got better so where they
are now to where they first were is
completely different the thing about the
bear is it's become the perfect muse not
just in the sense that it's been
successful and helped me be able to do
other artistic ventures that I want but
in terms of taking one concept not
having to worry about the concept but
evolving the mediums and exploring other
creative facets you know from casting
and painting and silk-screening and all
these things it's allowed me such a
perfect platform to be able to to
explore whatever I want to do so that I
can then apply that process once I learn
it to another project
[Music]
what is it being an artist me you know
like yeah I get it you know create every
painter you draw but really what is the
depths of that it's tricky do art for
yourself but art can also be public and
once it goes into the public hand it
falls into a completely different
category of like you're really you're
really opening up your heart and you're
really opening up your soul on your
spirit so it's a little bit scary
sometimes no matter what the fact that
that somebody takes the time to spend
their hard-earned money to get something
that makes them feel good which comes
from something that I do it's like a
really beautiful kind of full circle